On the Friday that just passed,
a young beautiful 23 year old teachers aid was killed,
murdered by her ex partner,
a man. Eighteen Australian women have died from gender based finance
this year alone. It's surpassing our usual average of one per week,
which is still not good enough.
And for all my US followers,
Australia's not that big. So proportionally,
that's still a lot. Yeah.
And so I've been having a lot of conversations about this.
And one of the trends that experts are noticing
is that violence against women,
men's violence against women is not getting better.
We've got all these awareness,
we've got all these services.
We've just come along way in so many ways.
And yet, so
why are the statistics
not showing us the results that we'd be expecting
potentially to see by now?
In fact, it seems to be getting somewhat worse
as women of all ages become more empowered.
The reaction against that by some men is proportionate to that.
Women in their 50s are leaving their husbands
because they've just figured out
I don't have to do this anymore.
I actually could go off and live a better life without this,
with this abusive relationship.
Gen Z women have grown up in this feminist environment basically
where they've got the world at their fingertips,
like all this information and they're standing up for what they want.
They feel empowered to lead a different life
to the life of their parents
and Grandparents, men are being left behind.
They're not catching up to that.
They still have been born into this entitlement,
that they feel entitlement over a lot of things,
including women in our body.
And they're still stuck in the man box
whereby
they don't know how to process their emotions in a healthy way.
They feel entitled over women.
And when women reject them,
which women are doing increasingly,
or they feel like they don't have full control over women,
which is happening more and more,
they are still reacting in the same ways that they always have.
So when men say, no,
for real, we've grown to hate you,
it isn't the patriarchy. It's what's become of you.
I don't see that as something to laugh about.
I see that as a very real problem
that results in the deaths of real women.